bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono la vj much doveri che
quindi siamo su etv
ma ragazzi siamo su itunes come mai
prima d'ora prima grazi questo qualcosa
che è successo allo zen jones con sono
andato qualche settimana fa a mio parere
ragazzi lo ricorda tantissimo sia per
ambientazione perché è più o meno
lamentazione anche di gta
per farvi un esempio
esigeva da poco che cosa esageratamente
figure più ragazzi io ero vestito come
steve di via pc questo sono io e questo
e steam
porca [__] sono uguali niente ragazzi
mi lascio al video e noi ci vediamo dopo
se sarò ancora vivo da ragazzi bene
questo io sono gay
oggi siamo sulla piece primi hanno
migliorato la grafica di happy wings e
adesso è così
[Musica]
e poi fermarsi però se va dalle 12 in
poi i costi
che cosa ha detto ho capito un cazzo
siamo per preparare lorenzo per happy
wings che cosa tragica rispetto a quelli
che continuano rinnovabile più facile
ap wheels di lorenzo ostuni non deve
piegare le ginocchia sta preparando a
morire
sei pronto attraversare l'america
attravero vabbè dai ok siamo pronti a
ragazzi che cosa succede se si unisce
con gta europa una roba fuori
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la nostra mente di andare a trovare
estiva ragazzi solo da trovare perché
che bel caschino vince che bello il
verso il gabbiano all'ipad c'è scritto
ci fanno il culo li peggio sono i pedoni
ali del padre culo dai firl alterniamo
sulla ciclabile la ripresa posto mi
faccio arrestare ma veniamo parla di
abuso di casa dove parte e siamo col
coni segue diete wyss ed in gta 5 ei
sarebbe ancora vivo personaggi digitali
a mettervi starla quindi hai capito ben
gta fa vj capace che ma restano se mi
vedo più
e cantante
restano senza tetto beccano qui non
possiamo andare questi corsi ma che
morde sciarretta siamo con questi
personaggi non potremo mai essere cosi
se vent'anni si chiama zio studio red
dust bella ziveri non c'è neanche la
stiamo
ancora abbiamo fatto il quartetto come
si è spento collisione con cui si è
spento fermo stretto allora staccata che
attacca e stacca
line ai raid funziona o vinca sudato
freddo va bene anche c'è stato bisogno
dell'arresto si alza arrestato lui siamo
in mezzo a cos'è successo
finiva l'america non ce l'ha più america
di padoin cazzo siamo siamo andati nelle
parti imparare a guidarla è un macello
ci ho messo un'ora e mezza non si guida
neanche con le mani basta andare avanti
così col corpo tipo così ma va
velocissimo lato poi 40 l'ora non so
neanche dove cazzo siamo arrivati ma non
potremmo stare quei costi cosi perchè è
il è illegale venire qui intorno bike
siamo andati avanti km nella baia di
come cazzo si chiama sabya quelle la
baia di che cazzo ne so non possiamo
stare ma neanche tra un chilometro
potremmo stare quindi dobbiamo pregare
di tornare da dove siamo arrivati senza
che ci veda la polizia sono più [__]
qui in gt r
sei serio eccoveli sinciziale sì un rpg
a questo punto sarebbe già crollato
[Musica]
precedente
[Applauso]
[Musica]
un po strega è un boss e l'ho incontrato
dove me lo sposo adesso
ragazzi questo è stato il mio è stato il
mio straight to los angeles ho dovuto
ottenere questo video per domenica non
l'ho messo nel blog perché dio mio è
troppo fi
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuta
comunque per la cronaca al tizio alla
fine questo qui era un drogato
l'abbiamo incontrato a venice beach mi
fa fare l'ho fatto ballare un pochettino
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto io concludo che l'episodio che
ho messo detto subito è piaciuto questo
momento mi piace anche la borsa di
facebook e camerali vita fatta
descrizione diversi dischetti diavolo
proseguito bella ragazza